Ben Shapiro is getting into it with
Tucker Carlson Shapiro responds Tucker
Carlson's moral equivalency struggle
session here and I'll play a little bit
uh from Ben for you guys and Tucker by
the way then continued along these lines
he did an interview with v ramaswami and
he likened what just happened in Israel
the the kidnapping of women and their
rape I mean he's showing video of this
happening like as he's talking about
this he compared that to drug overdose
deaths in the United States now I I
believe we should fully care about the
100,000 drug overdose deaths that
happened in the United States these are
two completely different issues to to go
this far a field to link the issues the
only reason you're doing this is because
you wish to downplay the atrocity that
just happened in Israel you're not up
playing the atrocity of what's happening
on America streets those are two
different types of atrocities people who
are addicted to fentanyl sticking
needles in their arms and overdosing is
a is a is a moral blight it is a moral
atrocity and a moral evil for people to
kidnap women rape them and drag them
back to the Gaza border those are not
the same thing so uh oh man this is
interesting saying that Tucker is trying
to downplay the atrocities of what
happened that's a bold statement from
Tucker let me play a little bit here
from um Ben I from Ben sorry let me play
a little bit from Tucker here I I got to
say you you mentioned moral outrage and
and I thought the videos from Southern
Israel were morally outrageous and I I
was offended by them and and saddened by
them anyone who saw them I think was um
but you don't have to look far in the
United States for moral outrages also on
video and there's not a city in this
country not just the big cities but
cities of 10,000 people I was in one
yesterday that doesn't have some
constellation of drug addicted young
people living outside we call them the
homeless they're drug addicts and
they're addicted to drugs that were
imported across an open border Allowed
by the Biden Administration and they're
dying more than 100,000 a year now you
could call it genocide you can call it
whatever you want but it's the death of
over a 100,000 Americans a year and the
living death of millions more who are
living outside so this is interesting
because Tucker is talking about 100,000
young people dying from these failed
policies Ben's making it seem like he's
just comparing drug overdoses in general
to what we just saw happen in Israel I'm
curious you guys think whose team are
you on team Tucker or team Shapiro well
obviously here's Ben Shapiro putting a
muzzle in someone's back because he's
not crying hard enough about you know
Ben's number one issue I I assume it's
like what is Tu Tucker's being very
consistent he's extremely nationalistic
populist and is making a point of yes
we're all horrified by these images but
you know I'm focused on my country I
mean this it's very true to who he is I
mean he's not saying this is outrageous
or anything why Ben's upset that
Tucker's not angry enough I think we're
all pretty angry about it I mean that's
why he had 30 minutes of a show
dedicated to it with VC and he want to
say let's not forget what's happening in
our own country where's the outrage here
I wish we were all as outraged about
what's happening in our country as we
are about what's happening in Israel
right now seems to be what he was
getting at but that's not good enough
for Ben chapiro apparent or Ukraine when
we were all putting up the flags in
Ukraine I wish that we cared as much
about what was happening to the people
in Appalachia when they were being given
uh opioids at in mass and then being
made fun of in private emails I mean I
am not saying that these things are even
comparable I think both parties are
maybe making a weird comparison but
there is definitely tragedy in America
and it is good to acknowledge that we
don't get we don't whip ourselves into
the frenzy that we have 100,000 dead
over this stuff a year yeah I mean
that's that's it's it you know like I
said is saying one a person oding on on
heroin is is is a moral blight but it's
an atrocity to kidnap rape women and
drag them to the Gaza border okay well
Tucker had 100,000 dead so you know we
we can talk about like I absolutely
agree in in in the sense of what Ben is
saying that yes beating raping women and
kidnapping them and dragging the guys a
border is is a moral atrocity well
beyond someone overdosing but Tucker
saying 100,000 people overdosing I think
gets to the point of something very
serious here yeah poisoning an entire
system Society the entire Society right
yeah a different kind of attack but here
here here's the other thing I'll add to
this too it's
like there's a video uh uh I don't know
I don't know if there was a video
there's a story out of Philly where a
woman was raped on a train in front of a
bunch of people I think they filmed it
oh yeah uhhuh yeah so women are being
beaten raped and kidnapped all the time
in the United States because of the
crime and because of the policies of
these soft these soft un crime Democrats
these policies are resulting in
criminals being released and then we
just had that woman in Baltimore who was
presumably raped and uh murdered on her
roof this Tech CEO now you've got the
the guy in in uh you've got the guy in
New York Ryan Carson I think his name
was who was stabbed and killed so you
know look I can understand organized
actions by Hamas into civilian areas is
an atrocity but I I think Tucker is
making a a relevant point he maybe could
have articulated a little bit better if
you wanted but he mentioned 100,000
deaths that's what you would call
derailing uh what Tucker did he derailed
the conversation into another uh
direction that he wanted seg he took
them into a tangent yes a tangential
segue so we lost it's his show but does
not watch Tucker Carlson it would become
so out of character if Tucker Carlson
came on and started like we need to go
to war and this is the worst thing
that's ever happened the history of
mankind if it were about another country
you know this is this is the other thing
this this is Tucker Carlson doing a
segue in a conversation you'll say yes I
do understand that you like the color
blue something else that's blue is the
sky have you noticed in the sky we do it
all the time on this show I do it
particularly I do free association where
if you're talking about a color I might
mention something else that the same
color you're like that's not what we're
talking about we're talking about this
that's derailing Segways are different
from you're derailing me right now
anyway we're joking Segways are when we
will talk for 15 or 20 minutes and then
we'll say we'll be talking about fake
news and I'll say speaking of fake news
we have this article we segue on by
saying they caught the end of his
segment on on the attack and then they
the beginning of his segment on the drug
overdose he's trying to shift the
conversation from Israel into American
issues by saying you know these things
are really really bad we have some
things that we're really concerned about
here in the United States too normal
segue because he has a presidential
candidate on right and he spent the last
20 minutes talking I I look man I like
Ben and I respect his anger frustration
um he's probably really scared he
probably has a lot of friends over there
I mean absolutely his family and friends
Terri happening he was there I don't
remember I could have misread a tweet
online oh I don't know going put up this
thing being like Ben is safe he's just
observing the the holiday so he's not on
well I could be totally off on this
nobody I I I completely respect Ben's em
like emotional state he's he's highly
he's he's highly agitated I don't mean
that to be mean I mean he's clearly this
is affecting his family probably his
friends definitely uh there there there
I'm sure that you know he may know
people who are who are victimized
injured maybe even killed but I just
want to say on top of all that cooler
heads prevail and now isn't the time to
be like criticized in Tucker Carlson for
doing a segue and maybe you know if Ben
had approached it more calmly being like
Tucker you could do a better job please
let's I think it would have hit would
have landed better but again I can
understand why Ben's upset I'm not
trying to be a dick yeah apparently he
left just before it happened just so you
know yeah W just before and and he
wasn't on the internet either because
they were observing Sabbath so ex do you
think it would be a good time to bring
like Israeli Scholars and uh or or I
guess to say Jewish Scholars and Muslim
Scholars together for a conference they
do that all the is it good to do right
now or is it I we had Max talking about
it and it's just like it's it's it's
never enough it's just maybe if we do it
we could publicize it to another it's
like a new crowd culture War episode we
get an Imam and a rabbi and a priest we
could that would be epic it be super
interesting the thing is though like
those are good and it's good when people
who are um expert in their field they're
they're studying their religion whatever
it's good for them to talk about things
but you have to remember the people on
the ground are making decisions to
participate in in either side of this or
not and so someone having sort of like
an elite group of Scholars having a
conversation doesn't mean that it's
going to affect the hearts and minds of
the people that are actually living in
the realities of both of these now
honest I'm most concerned about the kids
that are nine they're going to be 22 in
11 12 13 years and remember this like
the kids in 2009 that whose sisters were
blown up they're all in their mid early
20s and they're ready to fight I'm
talking about like the the Palestinians
that were there during the Israeli
attack in 2009 or whatever you want to
call it so it it for in those situations
maybe if we're if we have conversations
early now in these 11 12y olds that have
lost their family members have something
to listen to then maybe that'll help
them clear you know think properly over
the next couple decades while you know
that's like the best I can do is is just
talking on a microphone other than going
to Gaza which I want to do
too yeah I I think that it's not wrong
to want to have conversation I just mean
that the it's easy for us to who who
don't live in the middle of these
countries to say well if we just talk
about it more then maybe we'll be able
to reach an agreement and I don't live
with the cultural and religious um
complicated feelings that come with both
of these places I I live in America and
I'm Christian so some of the things that
go on are things that would be very
difficult for me to understand I don't
know that we are in a position to offer
a solution because and you know like all
conflict and war in history it's so
deeply complicated and it's uh not just
like one thing happened and suddenly
their fight this is a very layered
complicated um T contentious
relationship that has hit a very serious
breaking point and resulted in very
serious violence yeah it's like it's
been a thousand years you know it's not
it's not like it's just going to go away
tomorrow that's one thing that you can
sh for sure it's not going to just end
because some people discuss some things
and someone viewed them as being there
because even within Islam they have
different opinions as to who leads like
the spiritual successor of Muhammad on
Earth so it's it's not going to be that
easy I just I know what you're saying
and I get it it's Noble but outside of a
culture War episode I don't know I want
to do a new show maybe every Tuesday uh
one to two to three hours where we we
fly in religious experts it could be
anybody but if you guys support that in
the audience give me a five in the chat
because uh I've been thinking about a
lot and I don't think wasting time makes
any sense anymore but I mean the entire
region only well only functions with
strong men in power looks what happened
when they took out Gaddafi I mean there
there are such things as cultures that
really only understand force and power
yeah it's true I mean Russ culture they
only understand Sports and power they
want a strong man I think that's hard
for us to understand you say like yeah
it's hard for us to understand like well
let's just talk about it local cops
we've got this local protective bubble
that we all live in so it's it doesn't
really matter if your president's an
idiot sometimes right yeah exactly but
it's not true it does matter on the
geopolitical stage just doesn't really
matter as much domestically whereas in
Russia if you're president or in Chile I
don't know if the do the Russians have
local cops or is it federales all across
the Federation I I don't remember
exactly I remember that I I'm pretty
sure it's Federation cops I think
so Federation cops want to ask you a
question about Tucker really quickly
were you uh did you see a shift in his
style because you observed him pretty
closely from when he left Fox and now
that he's doing
something um well you know he's very
he's still an employee of Fox News so
he's uh under constraints about what
he's able to do but just the style of
his interviews style of his interviews
uh I think that his I think he's I mean
it's a different show now cuz it's long
form I guess it's more similar to that
Tucker Carlson Today's Show I think that
he's probably
um I think probably the lack of
structure is probably affecting him a
little bit I think positively or
negatively uh I think he's just probably
getting used to it because he's worked
like a jobby job for yeah a 100 years in
cable news you know I think that the
kind of freedom and lap structures maybe
is this something you kind of go into in
his book Tucker's time in media yeah I
mean most of the book is um I mean it's
you know his birth well not even his
childhood his father's childhood well
before that up until the book ends two
weeks after he was taking taking off the
air and he's sort of still dazed by it
and going through it how' you meet him
uh I was a regular on his show I I was
first actually when I came out
conservative which was in a piece in the
New York Post uh came out conservative
yeah when I came out conservative that
was a headline I'm a gay New Yorker and
I'm coming out conservative that was and
that coming out might have been harder I
don't actually oh it was it was much
harder way harder than coming out 15 in
the middle of the country I hear you man
um but that was February 2017 and he had
me on the show because of that article
which went viral which I had no idea it
would had you been writing biography
before that uh not I'd written um
magazine profiles tons of those uh but
not this is my first biography how long
did it take to write it this book was um
a little over a year were you like in
constant contact with Tucker as you were
writing it like yeah I was yeah he was I
try not to bother I bothered him as
little as possible try to respect his
time but I spent tons of time with him
in his home and stayed his home by his
insistence and so would you go interview
him take a bunch of notes then leave go
write as much as you could and then come
back and hit him up again kind of thing
thing uh I tried to get it done in like
chunks so I would come hang out for a
few days at a time have my recorder
going the whole time and just kind of be
there and then get home transcribe it
all go through it because I'd already
done you know I there's a lot more you
know when you're writing about someone's
career and all that there's so much more
you're already working on to there's a
lot of history there there's a lot of
words there tons of that you know yeah
did you find that it changed you uh
learning about someone else and writing
someone else's biography it did yeah uh
I think with him particularly and and
his wife suie it it made me not to sound
corny but uh it made me chill out a bit
it made me kind of remember what was
important in life what do you mean just
because he's such a he has a very um
he's he he is not nomaniac he's not a
jerk he's a really sort of warm and
interesting person he has a very
Balanced Life he's he makes sure he can
see the stars every night you know
things like that uh and I've been
talking a lot about that he's very into
nature and uh and he has a really lovely
life and lovely family and so it was
sort of one of those like yeah I need to
remember what's important it's not
what's happening in the news he's
someone who very much knows that what's
happening in the news is not the most
important thing in the world and that's
ironic him being at the time as he was
number one on Fox you know when I was
doing most This research I find myself
wondering about that with America I mean
all of Western the world but definitely
America's workaholic culture you see
people especially women delay having
children or getting married because they
think oh my career needs come first they
need to get to a certain level and we
know ultimately you know you can always
be more successful you can always be
working for something more whereas uh
I've quoted this a couple times one of
the it was the guardian I think
published this story interviewing men
who hadn't had children and they just
kept saying Oh I thought it would happen
so you have these two forces saying I
had my I didn't put my eye on this thing
that ultimately makes life sort of have
a meaning that you can't just get from
dollars and cents or promotions at work
yeah that that that was something I I
discovered is that he's so he's so much
more interested in in the big bigger
questions of morality Family Faith
Beauty than he is in politics per se
yeah you know which are far more
interesting conversations and the reason
we're supposed to have politics in the
first place to uphold our morality and I
think a part of his success was he's the
only person that could speak on those
things in mainstream media number one he
because he actually believed them and he
wrote all those monologues himself but
you know he could do a segment about
architecture like Sean handy can't do a
segment of architecture he doesn't care
about architecture you know and also as
you brought up starting Families how
young women get screwed by feminism and
and all these other lies that they've
been and young men as well which we
don't talk about a lot which he
certainly does no thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 pm and become a member
over at timcast.net